i'm aware of what's going on with my
brother i'm family first
job second he's not fredo guys he's not
freighter remember if you say
that chris cuomo is the dumber younger
brother he's smart
not like everyone says not like dumb
like smart and he wants respect
cnn just disgraced itself
once again according to the washington
post
chris cuomo took part in strategy calls
advising his brother
this is not a shock in any way shape or
form i mean it's pretty obvious this is
going to happen the only thing that's
humiliating about this for cnn is that
chris cuomo got caught
and the fact is that jeff zucker was on
the phone with like donald trump during
the 2016 campaign
members of the media are constantly
strategizing with other members of the
democratic party because the media is an
entirely democratic run operation at
this point
there's a reason why ap and hamas are
are in the same building
ap does propaganda work for hamas in the
gaza strip
the the notion that the media does not
have very cozy relationships with the
people that it covers is just insane
which of course is why the entire media
is out in defense of chris cuomo today
despite the fact it should be a pretty
humiliating headline according to the
washington post
cnn anchor chris cuomo advised his
brother new york governor andrew cuomo
and senior members of the governor's
staff on how to respond to sexual
harassment allegations made earlier this
year
by women who had worked with the
governor according to four people
familiar with the discussions
cuomo one of the network's top stars
joined a series of conference calls that
included the democratic governor his top
eight his communications team
lawyers and a number of outside advisors
according to people familiar
with the conversations the cable news
anchor encouraged his brother to take a
defiant position and not to resign
at one point he used the phrase cancel
culture as a reason to hold firm
in the face of the allegations in a
statement
cnn acknowledged that chris cuomo took
part in the strategy sessions saying his
involvement was a mistake
he said chris has not been involved in
cnn's extensive coverage of the
allegations against governor cuomo
on air or behind the scenes in part
because as he has hit on the show he
could never be objective but also
because he often serves as a sounding
board
for his brother well weird because he
covered him for a year on covid
well he was covering up nursing home
deaths while he was lying to the public
he was covering his own brother on the
air for a year
the statement says it was inappropriate
to engage in conversations that included
members of the governor's staff
which chris acknowledges he will not
participate in such conversations
going forward the anchor said he was
walled off from coverage of the governor
without mentioning the special
dispensation
he received from cnn to feature him on
his show during the pandemic
the episode illuminates how the cuomo
brothers who are 13 years apart at age
have benefited from their respective
high purchase in politics and media
shocker early in the coveted pandemic a
top department of health doctor was
dispatched to the hamptons to test chris
cuomo
and his family the washington post had
previously reported
former and current administration
officials said the anchor played an
active role early in the governor's
coronavirus strategy because he's
strategizing
with cuomo on kovid and then covering
him on cnn
this is not a shock the brothers
sometimes fish together in the waters
off long island okay
i i can't avoid he's not fredo guys he's
not freighter remember if you say
that chris cuomo is the dumber younger
brother he's smart
not like everyone says not like dumb
like smart and he wants respect
he's not fredo cause apparently
according to chris cuomo if you say that
he is like fredo like the stupider
younger brother who's being dragged
around based on the family name if you
say that
then obviously that is like he said that
was like the n-word for some reason
which is weird because the godfather is
like about
an italian crime family and um i really
don't think that the ethnicity of the
cuomo's has much to do with the fredo
reference it's one of the most iconic
references to a dumb younger brother
a dumb older brother actually in the
history of cinema but
in any case the governor only trusts
about five people one advisor with
knowledge of the strategy session said
so that's why chris
is on these calls oh inside cnn on
thursday several employees described a
sense of
unease about the role cuomo played in
advising his brother with one calling
his decision to do so
really upsetting oh well i mean if
you're upset another person said that in
a political climate in which cnn
journalists come under intense scrutiny
having one of their own offering advice
to a major democratic figure felt like a
self-inflicted wound
this one yes it is we were saying this
the entire time
you had him on national tv joking about
does mom love you best
doing smothers brothers routine he's got
giant q-tip
he's got a big nose
hey now just a couple of flashbacks here
so first of all cuomo has now apologized
so he went on air last night he
apologized for this uh-huh
i believe him i can be objective about
just about any topic but not about my
family
those of you who watch this show get it
like you i bet
my family means everything to me
and i am fiercely loyal to them
i'm family first job
second i understand why that was a
problem for cnn
it will not happen again it was a
mistake
because i put my colleagues here who i
believe are the best
in the business in a bad spot i never
intended
for that i would never intend for that
and i am sorry
for that okay so here's the thing it's
the most obvious conflict of interest in
media history right i mean his
own brother he's advising him on kovid
and then he's covering him on air
doing joking routines about how he's the
best governor in america and how there
are homosexuals and such right
you remember this okay it was perfectly
obvious this was a conflict why did it
never occur to chris cuomo that it was a
conflict
why did it never occur to the cnn higher
ups that this was inappropriate and the
answer is because they all have the same
relationship with the democrats that
chris has with his brother
that's the answer these people have the
same relationship with the biden
administration
and had with the obama team as chris has
with his brother
when it comes to the media blood is only
slightly thicker than the water that
passes between
the the media and their democratic
sponsors
okay the reality is that the anchors on
cnn are constantly advising people
in the democratic hierarchy about what
they think they should do
now listen i'm a politically biased
observer i talk with republicans
i advise some republicans i'll tell you
when i've talked to the republican
advisor republican but you know my
political bona fide he's out front i am
not hiding them
the difference is that cnn pretends it's
objective cnn pretends that they are not
lying to you
cnn pretends that they are not biased in
any way that they are somehow a higher
level of news
they're only embarrassed they got caught
and they did get caught
right flashback to chris cuomo not all
that long ago saying yeah it's kind of
unusual that i cover my brother but it's
just something we have to do
me having you on the show is an unusual
thing we've never really done it uh but
this was an unusual time
and there were unusual needs and you
stepped up in an unusual way
that really was created by a vacuum of
power on the federal level you're not
the only one there were other governors
you've been very good and collaborative
with
hogan down in maryland and whitmer and
dewine and the ones up in the northeast
region
um but these unusual times have uh
demonstrated
some unusual characteristics in people
i'm sorry
so he was openly admitting the conflict
of interest way back when
but then as soon as it was sexual
harassment he's like oh i can't cover it
he's my brother
we all noted the idiocy of this at the
time
obviously i'm aware of what's going on
with my brother
and obviously i cannot cover it because
he is my brother now of course
cnn has to cover it they have covered it
extensively
and they will continue to do so
i have always cared very deeply
about these issues and profoundly so
i just wanted to tell you that there's a
lot of news going on that matters
also so let's get after
that okay this is
it's ridiculous but it is cnn in a
nutshell this is cnn
this is cnn an apple is an apple a
banana is a banana
and these reporters cover people that
they love and advise on a regular basis
and chris cuomo just got caught
did you know that every single like
creates one additional leftist tier
that is just science